do you guys think people deserve love
everyone deserves love absolutely not
that type of [ __ ]
okay okay so you say no why no it's
something you earn love is very special
it's sacred it shouldn't just be given
to anybody because it wouldn't have
value if you if you're grumpy if you're
rude if you don't do anything what what
is there what is there to admire about
you
okay what do you got you guys said yes I
said everyone deserves love in a sense
where you know someone needs to be loved
by someone whether that's your mama your
dad that's loving you
like they need love but in terms of like
me giving love to someone then yeah not
everyone can just get my love because my
love isn't just something that I just be
throwing out I'm a very like protective
of it
for me I also agree with you I'm don't
remember your name
um yeah not everyone deserves love
because some people are just too evil
too Wicked too spiteful and they don't
have Pure or good intentions or they try
to manipulate you or deceive you or like
love for me and then change into a
completely different person so no not
everyone deserves love
um so I I kind of half agree with the
thingy like loving a relationship no but
loving a family I think it should be but
at the same time that's more like
responsibility than than actual love
because there are parents out there who
generally just don't love their kids so
it's not it's not um what's it called I
don't know that word where it's like you
have to do it or whatever but yeah so I
would say no in relationships
um does everyone deserve love no but
people do everyone deserves
acknowledgment and like just making you
feel like you exist to someone like it
doesn't have to be full on love but at
least appreciation
do you feel like homeless men are
appreciated
some of them I
think maybe by and large like in general
they probably were at some point in time
yeah you think so yeah I I'd say
exceptions or something like that but
but other than that it's really hard to
look like oh this person doesn't pay
money into the tax system this person
doesn't you know that like it's very
hard to look at him it's cruel I'm not
saying that you should but I think
General people just walk past and think
like what are you doing well I think
when you say acknowledgment it's from a
woman's point of view because we're used
to getting attention we've gotten
attention from like the what the day
we're like 13 14 whenever you started to
like become womanly but like there's a
large portion of men that like don't get
attention ever
um I wouldn't say just like from being a
woman I'll just say it just like being
human in general because like the word
the world has become very like focused
on image and social media where people
have lost a sense of humanity so in that
sense no I I understand what you're
saying but I just think it's not reality
like if you walk past a homeless man
you're not going to give him any
attention or pay him any mind in general
I might give him some change or food you
might even a look is an acknowledgment
like you just you looking away and
acting like you don't see that person
then that's you just you don't care
basically okay what do you think
um in relationships yeah love doesn't
really work but for family love is very
important
quick question is oh yeah so
um I've got your name Deontay Deonte
just repeat what you said um about
spiteful
um I don't even remember but about the
most people deserve love you're like no
no yeah like some some people they're
spiteful or Wicked like they they don't
have good intentions in their heart or
they go out to destroy other people
because of their past experiences or
because of their trauma or because of
they've been hurt by a female or family
member or whatever else and in order for
them to move forward they don't move
forward with like their best foot or
something to say isn't that like a
little girls
I just see baby mom
to my head right now really can you can
you um give like expand because I don't
really understand like the point of view
that you're buying from manipulative
yeah all these other negative words yeah
and when when you say these words I
think about a lot of women like you said
women have sex trauma uh women get
spiteful because men treat them as
certain etc etc they don't enter new
relationships with the best intentions
right because you don't have to work on
yourself because everything's been given
to you yeah especially if you're an
attractive woman so I feel like all
those words just pop out there yeah
describes a lot of women into this but I
feel like I don't know if you recalled
the question was does everyone deserve
love you said no yeah and then you
describe those words that's what I'm
that's why I said that sounds like a
woman to me I just wanted to get you
um okay well um so would you say bitter
baby mamas don't deserve love
um sorry the some don't let's be let's
be real like some don't because
um
if you're going if you're going to be
really honest with yourself
um which a lot of people aren't
um they if we're talking specifically
about baby moms like a lot of baby moms
or baby fathers
um use the child as a um form yeah as a
as a porn in order in order to get
certain things from the ex-partner in
order to make a point and stuff like
that so like I do understand what you're
saying but I just feel as though like if
we're looking at it a lot deeper let's
just examine Humanity rather than
examine oh yeah it's just a baby mum
because that's not always the scenario
in which we look at Society so but did
did the man make her crazy or was she
already like that because you're the one
who decided to have a chance
why is it why do we always whenever we
put accountability on women we always
flip it and then blame the man because
it's just like oh so I said I said
bitter baby mamas so I didn't say oh
and then you and then your first
reaction is well what about the man yeah
of the man you know men talk they say a
lot of stuff they feed you lies and you
know they make you feel a certain way so
therefore you might have to start acting
exactly yeah but you don't have to act
you don't have to act psycho like that's
a choice like you chose to act psycho
yeah but it's mental health in it
maybe the guy drove it to that point I
mean here's the thing I've been in a
toxic relationship before I don't do I
never did the crazy [ __ ] I see a lot of
these girls do on social media that's a
choice everyone reacts differently yeah
I know but that's that's a choice that's
who you are that shows a lack of
character if that's how you react but
you don't like you know how much no
you're not you're not a child like
you're a grown adult yeah it makes
decisions it doesn't Define who you are
just like when you have arguments in a
relationship or even with your siblings
it absolutely there might be times where
you actually physically fight okay it
absolutely defines who you are the
actions that you choose when you are are
angry absolutely Define who you are if
if a man on the street got angry and
murdered somebody they wouldn't say oh
you didn't murder him it's okay
not necessarily but not to the judge the
world doesn't know you understanding and
and the thing is in life what Paul's
saying is like in life yet the only
thing you can control like literally the
only thing you can control is yourself
you you cannot control anyone else their
actions what they do but you can control
your own actions no matter what so
whatever you do you have to take account
accountability for whatever you've done
if you get robbed on the street or you
get thing you've walked down a bad
street or you weren't looking out for
things you still have to take
accountability of your actions no one's
saying that the person who robbed you
isn't a bad person no one's saying the
men that didn't treat you right isn't a
bad person but at the end of the day you
still have to take accountability for
your own actions because that's the only
thing you can control without saying no
one's saying you should take
accountability mental abuse is real so
you don't know what that could do to the
brain yeah like but you should be
if you
choose Choice as an adult to stay and
then you act a certain way because you
chose to say that's your own fault and
it says let me finish and it says
something about your character it says
something about your character because
if if it's in you to act crazy then
you're crazy I I agree with you
everybody
I agree with you but then like I just
believe that like we can't hold everyone
to a particular standard when like you
were saying about like people having
mental health issues or like if somebody
has driven the person crazy like we all
know that women are more so emotionally
inclined so sometimes yeah
say that say that again I said unstable
stable unstable whatever you define it
as but I just feel as though like
sometimes we don't necessarily consider
like a man's influence on a woman and
going back to like one of your um
questions earlier about how is it that
when like a question like oh the baby
mom is brought up why do women always
flip it back on on the man and I feel as
though partially that's a defense
mechanism because us as women we're all
we always get the um negative
um aspect of like what what life could
be or like some of our decisions and not
necessarily seeing anybody what do you
mean by the negative aspect um so say
for example
um two people got together they had sex
they had a baby
um so we're speaking about the baby mom
however like the baby mom has been
making specific choices to restrict the
man from seeing the child or whatever
um sometimes we don't necessarily see
that there are reasons behind it some
men are just wokless some men are um
yeah but so so are some women no no I
understand that let me kind of like
who's the gatekeeper of six pardon who's
the gatekeeper of sex the woman however
men are
but men can be manipulative men can sell
you a dream like
I I understand where you guys are coming
from but it's just like like I'm saying
like a man is more militant in in terms
of their expression oh um a man a man
does things to obtain
um sex women do things to obtain love so
the reason why a woman would have sex
with a man is because she feels as
though she will receive love from a man
the reason why a man says to a woman I
love you is because he feels that if he
says I love you he will receive sex from
her but then who's the fall in that
situation both of them not really
because he gets what he wants well so
you don't get what you want but you know
what that's a manipulation that is
that manipulation that's a good salesman
that's a good salesman think of think
about what my guy who was sitting there
earlier said when he said before when
men used to get involved with women you
needed another man's approval in order
to get that woman now women are
screaming this I'm independent I can do
all of my own and you're making hella
bad decisions then you say well don't
tell me I'm making bad decisions like I
just do what the [ __ ] I want to do
regardless of the repercussions as in
society yeah I for me that's ludicrous
that makes no sense but also what you've
got to remember is that we live in like
I think you were saying earlier not only
that but like we live in a hypersexual
Society like everywhere you look women
because of women I don't know women
resexualize ourselves look at I was just
at carnival this weekend the amount of
half naked women I saw that we sexualize
ourselves they're not just that if the
guy looks at you naked you're gonna be
like what the [ __ ] you're looking at but
scrub your cheeks are just in my face
yeah no that and I agree with that 100.
if I told you as my girl yeah that you
can't wear certain clothes you're gonna
feel away controlling yeah 100
because they want more attention out
there so if you're saying it's
controlling because you're still looking
for more attention from different men
yeah
no it's not I generally want to dress
because I want to adjust it okay you're
walking around with a for sale sign when
you have a man that's disrespectful like
you got you yeah
you want to wear and yeah yeah wearing
what you want to wear just because he
doesn't like what I'm wearing I'm so
what no I mean
one at a time one at a time guys
do you believe in submitting to a man
whose authority you trust to a certain
extent submission to me is very iffy
okay would you trust a guy's judgment
depends as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible